so dream what was it that made you say
yes to the role of gene um I might
manager around Mandel who I trust more
than anything on his opinion for scripts
and stuff like that and sent this over
to me and he was like you need to read
this script and I really fell in love
with this character Jane it was kind of
like you know I think she's struggling
to know who she is a little bit and I
think that she's also you know it's also
this beat I love the story of how she's
creating this bond with this older woman
who she doesn't know and how she's like
she really goes for it and building this
relationship and this kind of mother
figure for her and I think that
at the end of reading the script and
something it just leaves you wanting
more a little bit leaves it almost and
watching the movie needs kind of like a
satisfied but like I don't know makes
you want to do something a little bit
right how would you defend Jean someone
were to judge her because there were so
many beautiful parts to her and I'm sure
there are people that might judge her
but how would you defend her suppose she
was a friend of yours um listen I met a
lot of girls who were actually in the
porn industry and
a lot of them are so normal like they
way it's a job for them and it's it was
actually nice to see that
they weren't as messed up as I actually
thought that they were going to be or
not so unstable and it's some of them
are but a lot of them are you know they
go to they wake up they go to ballet
class they didn't care of themselves
it's their job and as much as for me I
don't agree with the profession you know
in a sense like I wouldn't do it but I
think that a lot of these girls deserve
to not be as judge and I think that
especially in the acting industry in any
industry there's a lot of judgment and I
think that's very hurtful and I think
that we need instead of you need to
discover a little bit on your own before
making pre judgments about people and
why was Jean so attracted to say aside
from wanting to return the money maybe
not having not knowing how to handle
Sadie's initial rejection why was she so
attracted to I think that she was
attracted to
I think that because she's so to
Jane initially and finding you know the
money and stuff like that instead of
returning it to her as wanting to figure
her out this woman and I think that it
was almost a game in the beginning and
then she also started to build this
relationship with this woman and and
really start to love her and I think
because she because Sadie was so
resilient against actually letting Jane
in but it was kind of almost like she
had to get there in some way it was his
challenge yeah interesting the said
kovitch scene in the film for you was
the most emotionally moving there were
so many looks that she portrayed where a
word this was you didn't utter a word
but you could just see a million
emotions which one seemed really
resonated with you
when she drive up in the car and the bus
wasn't the the taxi wasn't there and she
sounds so I can help you and I'm I can
feel my doubt and resentment and you
know what is she really doing and then
she comes to my house and helps me it's
like I'm not used to this kindness so I
don't know what to do with it I'm kind
of upset with it
but the second time she comes I begin
the counter then when I'm pushing in the
cart down the street and she's saying
he's saying yeah I'm here I'm here
and I thought what there was a cut there
was a kindness sir there was a
persistent yeah yes yeah like I wasn't
going to give up in a way yeah and so
that feeling of her being there was kind
of like I've never had it and all of a
sudden it's there and
I am tangling with my angry side and my
kind side so it's hard for me to see
this balance and until the very end when
she throws the things down I'm still
being but I'm so taken in by her
did I I mean and then she brings out all
those cars I just think that's kind of
amazing how hard she tries to be friends
and the roles come to you as Sadie now
and at this time in your life what do
you think now is the best opportunity
for you to act had you wanted to in
front of the camera what why now the
whole thing to me was was and is when
she Ching came to me and said of you
know you'd be what I get for a part of
the picture that were filming I really
think we can my inner voice was going
I mean doesn't she realized that imma go
away I mean what does who put us with
her all this is inside but she insists
on the picture and I'm like she's gotta
be hidden
this is a joke and then she said what
they like you could could we have your
phone number and I'm thinking wait a
minute the joke is giving me bigger and
maybe it's gonna be real so it was a
surprise though big huge surprise could
I do it again I don't know I had such a
good time with her I don't know if I
could do it
yeah I think Sean was brilliant him
giving what he wanted from the
characters and I think he did a
fascinating job and bringing that out
because I saw in myself I don't think it
could have done it but he
but I'm looking for her dog I'm crying
because it's real and that that scene
was for me I could do it this minute
because all I thought about was the
pictures on TV of animals that are are
and that's what made me feel the loss of
the dog and the pain so when she comes
to get him I'm so pissed looking for him
all day I'm gonna pitch it